[Musique]
nous sommes sur les terrains du stade de
porchefontaine aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur le rugby club de
versailles c'est parti
[Musique]
le rugby-club de versailles a été fondé
en
1893 pierre chevalier le responsable
communication du club est avec nous il
va nous parler de
l'histoire du club d'histoire et
versailles est une ville d'histoire et
de culture elle est devenue au fur et à
mesure en à la fin du 19e siècle une
ville de culture sportive et donc
effectivement les premiers les premières
passes de rugby dans la cour du lycée
hoche donc ça ne s'est pas tout jeune
donc fin du 19e siècle star 19e et
versailles est un des dix plus vieux
club de rugby de france le septième si
si on doit y est exact mais pourquoi ça
a pris à versailles justement plus
qu'ailleurs peut-être peut-être
justement 7,7 cette culture cette
culture et cette culture physique la
cour du lycée hoche avec avec les
premières les peut-être les premières
bribes de la culture britannique où est
né le rugby est avec justement 7,7
export du rugby d'angleterre en france
et peut-être au plus près de paris et
des villes culturelles sportives et et
sportives autour de paris du coup ça a
pas mal bougé à à versailles n'a pas
forcément été tout le temps ici à
porsche fontaine à quel moment ça c'est
localisé ici sur le terrain de deux
porsche antennes on part effectivement
d'une cour d'école et au fur et à mesure
on va dire que dans les années 50 60
le rugby se stabilise dans les environs
de porchefontaine évidemment pas sur ses
installations là et pas tel quel mais
elle est passée aussi autour de montbron
et des différentes enceintes sportives
de la ville de versailles vous avez une
idée ou pas du nombre de joueurs qui
sont passés sur sur cette erreur là il
faudrait qu'on fasse le calcul mais
depuis depuis effectivement son trente
et quelques années ça en fait beaucoup
parce que versailles est un est un club
formateur donc on y vient à tout âge on
est formé au rugby de l'école de rugby
jusqu'en jusqu'en seniors et même
jusqu'en vétérans avec l'équipe des
vieux crampons alors sur le terrain est
ce que versailles brille alors
versailles a toujours été un club
bien implanté en termes de régions
régionalement et au niveau national et
fédérales meilleur niveau atteint par
par le club en seniors c'est celui qu'il
occupe actuellement en fédérale 3 et
après viser plus haut c'est une histoire
d'ambition dont on parlera plus tard
[Musique]
nous sommes maintenant avec le maire de
versailles françois de mazières françois
de mazières qu'est ce que ça représente
pour vous le rugby-club de versailles
avec le rugby club de versailles c'est
essentiel à la ville de versailles de
bord c'est un club c'est le plus ancien
de ville de versailles c'est un club
exceptionnel qui a des beaux résultats
qui vit vous pouvez le voir dans un
cadre magnifique et puis maintenant qui
est animé par une équipe extrêmement
dynamique et avec des personnes qui
vraiment ont pris en charge comme moi
c'est un très beau club est très fier de
lui et comment la ville justement
soutien peut-être qu'on l'a on voit les
infrastructures là juste derrière
comment comment la ville aide en fait
finalement le rugby-club de versailles
alors vous avez raison le dire la ville
est d'abord les clubs sportifs pour les
installations les installations à ville
de versailles sont assez exceptionnelles
on bénéficie d'un cadre qui est un cadre
vais au bucolique vous pouvez voir ça
c'est très rare et je sais que les gens
qui viennent ici sont toujours contents
le découvrir c'est le premier atout le
deuxième atout c'est évidemment des
subventions elles ne sont pas conseillés
rhin parce que la ville de versailles
contrairement à l'image qu'elle doit
c'est une ville plutôt pauvre parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'activité économique
donc on note très fort il est
significatif notamment dans les
investissements d'où vient il ya
quelques années
faire un investissement important sur
les vestiaires du club sont très beaux
et il ya beaucoup de monde aussi un qui
vient pour encourager l'équipe de
versailles notamment le dimanche ici ça
arrive qui est 300 400 personnes des
fois autour du terrain absolument il ya
un esprit c'est le rugby aussi c'est un
esprit sain esprit je vais pas parler à
troisième mi temps mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya un peu de ça aussi ils sont très
solidaires et ça fait partie je disais
tout à l'heure un de l'histoire de cette
ville de versailles c'est un club qui
est vraiment ancré dans la ville on y
passe génération génération souvent et
ça fait partie vraiment aussi de la
formation et du quartier parce que ça
c'est un point sur lequel il faut
insister c'est que tous les responsables
de ce club sont conscients qu'ils
forment aussi les jeunes qui sont ici
dans le club merci pour ça nazir merci à
vous merci
[Musique]
l'échauffement on vient tout juste de
débuter ici assure le stade de
porchefontaine à mes côtés éric tournier
le président alors est-ce que tout est
en place quand on voit un échauffement
comme celui là bas ça ça commence là
puisque depuis le mois de juin il
s'entraîne donc on était impatients et
on est impatient effectivement surtout
les joueurs de débuter ce championnat
qui je l'espère va durer au moins
jusqu'à au mois de juin donc là il
s'entraîne deux mois je pense que on est
on est bien parti pour ce premier match
donc là on voit l'équipe une de cet
effectif comment vous trouvez cet
effectif quand vous l'avez façonné sur
cette nouvelle saison on a eu du temps
du coup à cause de la saison dernière
donc on a bien mon ami du temps on a
identifié les joueurs dans d'autres
clubs
ce qu'il manquait on a eu très peu de
turnover donc on est bien ciblé huit
nouveaux joueurs qui vont je l'espère
nous permettre d'accéder à la fédérale 2
mais comment on imagine un mercato quand
on est président de versailles justement
est-ce qu'on réfléchisse à l'adn du club
qui est plutôt familiale où est ce qu'on
va chercher peut-être des pépites un peu
venu de l'extérieur ça se passe comment
tout simplement dire que c'est un mixte
le premier critère serre est un club
familial donc on va chercher des
personnalités souvent on va les chercher
à travers le réseau des joueurs
on a suivi pendant un an deux ans on se
rapproche de on leur présente notre
projet et où il a deja si rapidement et
du coup ça nous permet effectivement de
pouvoir est au fait on avait terminé au
mois d'avril notre recrutement du coup
cette saison vous l'avez dit objectif
fédérale 2 c'est vraiment l'objectif du
club de pérenniser club au plus haut
niveau finalement c'est plus qu'un
objectif c'est j'ai bien insisté
dès le début oui c'est notre but
principal est au delà on va aller c'est
d'aller chercher un peu on chantait la
france
plusieurs tours et quand on fait pour
structurer un club comme versailles on
l'a dit c'est un club historique
1893 la municipalité vous est dans la
vue justement a précédemment avec le
maire de la commune qui est qui vous
soutient est ce que il faut chercher les
partenaires peut-être pour faire grossir
encore plus ce club c'est indispensable
on a effectivement le soutien de la
municipalité mais au-delà de ça on a le
soutien des licenciés puisque on a quand
même plus de 600 licenciés donc ça nous
permet effectivement d'avoir une aide
financière est bien évidemment les
partenaires 60 partenaires privés qui
nous ont suivis qui l'ont soutenu même
pendant la période du creux vide qui
nous accompagne depuis maintenant
plusieurs années et on a en en
perspective d'autres partenaires de plus
en plus important ces jeunes joueurs qui
évoluent à versailles ont eu 12 ans u14
est-ce qu'ils sont voués à venir jouer
ici a juste derrière nous sur cette
pelouse évidemment et d'ailleurs on a
cette année investi beaucoup sur dès le
plus jeune âge des derozan sur des
centres de perfectionnement donc on
attache beaucoup d'importance à notre
formation c'est notre adn afin de
pouvoir les amener le plus haut possible
vers notre objectif qui est la fédérale
2 donc oui on a intégré même dès cette
année dans le groupe senior encore trois
nouveaux
juniors qui vont passer un enseignant à
terme peut-être l'idée ce serait d'avoir
une équipe 100% versaillaise issus du
centre de formation
ça serait l'idéal maintenant on sait
très bien qu'on aura toujours des
manques sur certains postes donc si on
arrive à 80% l'équipe première de
versailles et ça serait ça serait
qu'ordinaire
le président éric tournier a parlé de
fédérale 2 dans les prochaines années
ici à versailles nous allons demander au
coach typhaine pour savoir ce qu'ils en
pensent alors typhaine qu'est ce que
vous en pensez tout simplement de cette
fédérale 2 dans les prochaines années
ici à versailles ça vous motive
j'imagine écoutez haut et ça motive
c'est un peu l'objectif que le club
s'est donné au travers de nouer de
l'effectif bien évidemment comme tout le
temps on consulte bas nos joueurs on
consulte un petit peu le groupe pour
savoir un petit peu où ils veulent aller
comment ils se sentent et quels sont les
objectifs qu'on pourrait mettre sur le
moyen et long terme et phyto
effectivement le club souhaite rejoindre
l'année prochaine la fédérale 2 qui vous
le savez va changer puisque les il va
avoir une profonde et des catégories et
l'année prochaine la division ça se
rappellera division 2 au lieu de
fédérale 2 voilà donc c'est l'objectif
de cette saison je vais pose également
la question antoine désolé je me mets
entre vous deux vous étiez en plein
exercice antoine a alors tout simplement
la fédérale 2 est ce que c'est possible
avec cet effectif vous faites partie des
anciens du club et aurait des anciens
tout à fait pas la fédérale 2 c'est tout
nouveau pour pour moi qui suis un ancien
ça jamais été un objectif du club vont
accueillir et fédérale 3 la descente en
honneur la remontée donc ouais ouais
c'est un super super objectif je pense
que le club le les coaches les deux
présidents toute l'équipe tout bureau on
fait vraiment le boulot pour recruter
des super joueurs donc ouais ouais bien
sûr qu'on y croie toute façon commencer
une saison sans y croire c'est ça
n'existe pas donc ouais on y croit dur
on a fait des belles saisons les deux
années précédant bon s'était coupé par
le comice et pour tout le monde pareil
mais ouais on a plein dans vie quand
ambitieux mais je pense qu'on a
l'effectif pour aller jusqu'au bout de
nos ambitions et ça se traduit comment à
l'entraînement on voit tous les hyper
motivés en ce début de saison webb a
beaucoup de sérieux c'est sûr bah les
places seront chères parce que comme je
vous le dis il ya beaucoup de
recrutements donc beaucoup de joueurs
pour chaque poste donc qu il va falloir
se battre pour ses places et se battre
pour sa place ça passe aussi par en tout
premier lieu par effectivement être
sérieux et assidu à l'entraînement donc
beaucoup de concentration mais c'est
bien mais est-ce que coach typhaine est
ravie de l'effectif bah oui forcément
puisque c'est moi qui l'ait voulu tiens
je vais pas dire il vaut mieux et voilà
il vaut mieux donc aujourd'hui comme
vous savez on a on a et à bien
informations sur justement les éléments
qui nous manquait pour réaliser
justement cet objectif ça fait trois ans
maintenant qu'on travaille très sérieux
heureusement avec le avec le club comme
vous savez on a une philosophie ici à
versailles d'être sur la formation et
sur nos jeunes donc la priorité est
quand même aussi d'intégrer un maximum
de jeunes sur notre équipe seniors et
sur l'équipe première on a encore la
chance cette année d'avoir une belle
génération de juniors qui va monter avec
des joueurs qui vont intégrer
directement le groupe le groupe une avec
des jeunes joueurs de 18 ans très
prometteur et qui vont pouvoir justement
grâce à sa faire passer un cap plus la
venue des joueurs extérieurs voilà sur
des postes bien ciblés jamais un
recrutement fait comme ça à la va vite
c'est vraiment fait sur sur des postes
sur des choses qui nous manquait pour
justement atteindre nos objectifs donc
oui effectivement nous on est on est
très content du recrutement et en plus
pour a passé un petit peu de mots et de
temps avec eux là je peux vous dire que
c'est vraiment plus des supers mecs
humainement donc c'est magnifique
et ici à verser aussi la philosophie
c'est de jouer de proposer du jeu
également pour pour le public on sait
qu'il ya énormément de supporters qui
viennent chaque week-end pour vous
soutenir est ce que c'est important de
leur faire plaisir aussi peut-être ben
je crois que de toute façon le but
aujourd'hui c'est le sport amateur on
est là pour s'amuser on est là pour
prendre du plaisir aujourd'hui nous ce
qui nous anime c'est c'est que tout le
monde vienne avec beaucoup d'entrain et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le fait de
proposer un jeu de mouvement et un jeu
d'évitement bah c'est quelque chose qui
nous qui nous plaît à tous donc
aujourd'hui on
essaie d'exceller de dents voilà des
fois on n'y arrive pas et des fois ça
fonctionne mais en tout cas on y met
plein de coeur pour que l'on puisse
réaliser justement ce fameux de jeu à la
versaillaise antoine le jeu à la
versaillaise ça sera encore pour cette
année le cul va le le collectif ultra
versailles est présent à chaque
rencontre il met beaucoup d'ambiance
faut leur faire plaisir ah bah ça c'est
sûr que vu le on a vu des années place
et le soutien qu'ils nous ont apporté
ces c'est vraiment essentiel il met une
sacrée ambiance donc pour reprendre un
peu ce que j'ai tiphaine évidemment leur
faire plaisir nous faire plaisir il pu
leur faire plaisir c'est vraiment
l'objectif on compte sur eux vraiment
très très fort sur cette saison parce
que voilà vue les objectifs l'effectif
est ce qu'on essaie de mettre en place
avec les coachs il y aura sûrement du
beau spectacle en tout cas on l'espère
et et si le peuple me concentrer je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
un club historique avec énormément
dormition dont une montée en fédérale 2
l'année prochaine et tout cela avec des
jeunes du club si vous voulez suivre
laventure dé versailles et a rendez vous
ce dimanche 26 septembre à houilles